I really want to give you a sincere
thank you for making me laugh too many
times to count wow thank you very much I
appreciate that that uh that course was
our goal uh but we wanted to tell a
story that did make you laugh but also
made you you know hopefully feel good
too because it's it's kind of a
feel-good story and it I the original
movie from uh Spain campions yeah I felt
that it had really captured that so we
wanted to recapture it in this
Americanized story I definitely want to
ask you you've directed with your
brother many things
um if someone has actually never seen
anything you've directed not counting
Champions what is the first thing you
want them watching and why boy that's a
good question uh
because all of our movies you know are
dear to us they're all a little bit
different uh I think that as far as my
brother and Pete go that we will
probably be defined by uh Dumb and
Dumber only because of the number I
think the number of laughs in it and and
that it that it kind of held up for so
many years when it first came out people
didn't know what to make of it uh but
nowadays I have kids I have nine and
ten-year-old kids come up to us in there
they've been watching Dumb and Dumber we
had no idea that it would it would it
would become a kids movie you know 30
years later but so that's the I think
that was the one that got us off and
running so that one is the one closest
to our heart probably which of your
films actually changed the most in the
editing room in ways you didn't expect
well as far as our films go the one that
changed the most uh in the editing room
was uh the movie fever pitch that we did
with Jimmy Fallon and Drew Barrymore and
it was simply because the the story was
about a guy who is loyal to his team
that was Boston Red Sox in the story
even though they break his heart every
year and and while we were filming the
movie lo and behold the Red Sox who
never win won the World Series that year
so so we had to uh we had to completely
change the Dynamics of what the end
happens at the end it sort of became the
more traditional Hollywood ending where
you know everyone wins and you know it's
a happy ending and all that but it
wasn't intended to be so uh so that one
wasn't was a bit challenging uh but
they're all they're all fun in the
editing room you can you can tweak it at
a lot of different ways but it's always
about you have to show it to an audience
and find out how they're reacting to it
and you make your changes accordingly
um Woody and Caitlin in this film have
fantastic chemistry the opening scene
for me when they're uh you know talking
in the in the bedroom I was like oh I'm
in for it these two are really good
together when did you realize that they
were going to be so good together uh
well I think the thing that blew me away
as I knew I knew Woody I've known him
for a long time but we've worked with
them before I always loved Caitlin Olson
mainly from her Tv show uh Always Sunny
in Philadelphia but she plays a
completely different character sweet D
very funny extremely funny but uh you
know kind of goofy almost in our movie
she plays a real woman that you can
really believe in I just thought she
gave such a beautiful performance I was
wowed by her I really was uh we've
worked with a I've had the pleasure to
work with a lot of great Leading Lady
comic actresses but she was as good as
any of them and very funny too I I just
really think the world of Caitlyn you
know I really sincerely think that the
two of them together were fantastic but
that was a big a key ingredient of the
movie you wanted to have that love story
behind it so that there's different
layers to the movie and that and that
was part of Woody's Arc too is that he
was a guy who was too lost in x's and
o's and being a basketball coach and not
not thinking about people I think
Ernie Hudson's character points that out
to him early on he says you have to
you've got to learn to read people you
gotta pay more attention to that as a
coach and and so over the course of the
movie by meeting her and getting to
coach the friends he becomes a much
better person and and that makes him a
better Coach I talk a little bit about
the importance of casting certain
um excuse me casting uh disabled actors
to play these roles right you know what
I mean because it's it's the it's
everything yes well you know over the
years a lot of there's been a lot of
Great Performances about disabled
characters played by non-disabled actors
a lot uh from Rain Man to you know tons
of them but that's just what people did
before because they said oh that you
know that that guy's an actor he can
play that part too but what's what's
good people have come to realize is that
people will real people with
disabilities have a hard time getting
into the movies they don't they very
rarely get read for a non-disabled part
and so when there is a disabled part in
a movie it's like well it should go into
people with real disabilities so the
world has changed in that regard and for
the better in that it's giving those
people a chance to play you know
basically themselves and so we were
committed to that we wanted to get real
you know disabled actors playing these
parts and we got real lucky when we
assembled this cast because they're all
excellent I think it's all of them but
are have never made a movie like this
and never you know worked with Woody
Harrelson and on this scale so what
surprised you about working with
non-professional actors
um and putting the you know filming this
well I'll tell you something if I had 10
friends at home who had never acted and
uh I threw them in a movie not
non-disabled people I'm talking about
I would have had every bit the challenge
that I and even more than I had with
these with these guys so there's no
difference they're they're these
disabled actors who were tremendous
there was I I didn't have to do a single
thing different as an actor I excuse me
as a director I all I had to do was was
trust them and let them play you know
little versions of themselves and they
were just as good as I could have
possibly hoped I mentioned editing
earlier in the interview uh but how did
this film possibly change in the editing
room in ways you didn't expect or how
did you tweak it you know what I mean
yes uh that's a that's a good question
there's a lot of ways that a movie gets
tweaked in the editing room uh I think
with this with this one the thing that
we worked out a lot is placing in music
key music where where needed and we had
a great composer in Michael Franti and
he really like drove the story in in
spots about how about just basically how
Marcus's character was feeling or should
have been feeling at a particular time
and so that's always a thing that you
find in the editing room is where to
place the music where to maybe leave out
music and and that sort of thing so
it's it's a it's an inexact science but
you learn as you go
um I have to rap but do you already know
what you're doing next ah yeah I do I'm
uh actually about to make a movie at uh
Paramount the studios right now it's a
Christmas story and it's uh it's a
fairly Brothers movie this one was you
know just me here but uh it's it's it
it's kind of a throwback to our more uh
raucous style of comedy and it's
Christmas Story at Paramount I look
forward to it thank you for giving me
your time